[Music]
meagan Markel has more to say about
being in the spotlight when I first met
my now husband my british-run said to me
I'm sure he's great but because the
British tabloids will destroy your life
two weeks ago the Dutchess of Sussex
caught candid about struggling with the
constant media scrutiny in the revealing
new documentary Harry and Megan in
African journey not many people have
asked if I'm okay but it's it's a very
real thing to be going through behind
the scenes now she's spilling even more
telling the Telegraph's Byron Gordon
that she doesn't want people to love her
she just wants them to be able to hear
her Gordon joined Megan last Friday
during her surprise appearance at the
opening of the luminary bakeries second
location which trains and employs
disadvantaged women Meghan's been a
supporter of the enterprise for some
time and even featured them in the
British Vogue issue she recently guest
edited
[Music]
Gordon reports that at the event Meghan
said one thing she's realized since
being in the UK is quote people have an
expectation when I'm coming somewhere so
I'm like let's just be really relaxed
keep everyone nice and chilled because
at the end of the day we're all just
women adding quote we all have a story
to tell and I feel honored that I'm
getting to hear yours according to
Gordon the 38 year old new mom humanized
herself telling the women that despite
all coming from different backgrounds
quote in these moments of connection it
becomes abundantly clear that our hopes
our fears our insecurities the things
that make us tick well those are very
much the same and there's comfort in
that last week female members of British
Parliament led by Holly Lynch offered
the Duchess comfort following the
lawsuit she and hubby Prince Harry filed
against associated newspapers after the
Mail on Sunday published a handwritten
letter that Meghan wrote to her
estranged father Thomas Markel you got
an unexpected phone call this morning
yes I did here in Westminster I got a
phone call it was booking on Palace
asking me was i available to speak to
the dentist of Sussex she was calling to
thank myself and other women MPs for
standing with her sending the open
letter to say we as women in public
affairs absolutely understand what she's
going through although in very different
public rolls we stand with her in
solidarity say that we shouldn't be
tearing down women in public line
through the press or otherwise and so
yes she was pleased to have seen that
letter in a world that can seem so
aggressive confrontational and dangerous
you should know that you have the power
to change it and everyone deserves to be
heard and respected
[Music]